welcome back to cbs mornings at 7 30. on
this 52nd earth day we continue our
earth 365 series it focuses on issues
affecting the health of our planet year
round and this morning we're looking at
a growing industry using wood pellets to
generate power now pellet producers call
it renewable energy but critics say the
industry is clear-cutting woodlands that
are an important line of defense against
climate change jonathan bigliotti went
to north carolina and virginia to
investigate whether these pellets really
are a green energy solution
every day thousands of acres of forests
are stripped bare logging in america
south known as the world's wood basket
is outpacing activity in the brazilian
rainforest i'm walking in what used to
be a more than 60 year old forest just a
few months ago it was chopped down to
this in just a matter of weeks an
estimated 6 million acres of forest are
managed and harvested each year for
products like lumber and paper
but a growing cut of america's woodlands
is going to a new industry that says
this
is green energy when people think of
green energy do you think this is what
they envision absolutely not i mean look
this looks like a bomb went off
as dana smith with environmental group
dogwood alliance explains forests are
turned into wood pellets
and burned by electric plants to
generate power
producers say the energy is green
because trees grow back the counter
argument here is you cut down trees like
this the carbon that's released through
burning them through the soil can be
absorbed by other trees that's just not
true just because they clear-cut this
forest
doesn't mean that somehow these forests
are absorbing magically more carbon out
of the atmosphere
smith took us to several clear cuts in
north carolina and virginia but four
years later you don't see much growing
back in this clear-cut wetland forest
her team traced these trees to enviva
the nation's largest producer of pellets
in viva declined our request to visit
their plants but vice president don
calloway says they only use leftover
wastewood like tree tops and limbs every
piece of fiber that's taken into our
process we can tell you that it's in
fact low value would if we did not
create this service it would be left to
rot on the fourth floor it would be left
to create forest fires foresters say
what we saw at in viva's plants was
something else
so we're here in a cotton field in
southern virginia where we've come to
see one of three in viva plants in the
region
[Music]
our drone captured entire trunks of pine
trees around 100 feet long and stacked
several stories high that could also be
used for paper production so when we
look at those images and i'm sure you've
visited the plants you've seen those
stacks of tens of thousands if not more
tree trunks i'm sorry to interrupt you
jonathan but it's important to not call
them tree trunks we take in tops and we
take in limbs and again to the naked eye
wood looks like wood i've never seen a
limb that tall and certainly in that
area again it can be the tops of a very
very large tree callaway says they never
clear-cut forests however in viva's own
public disclosures show 90 percent of
some harvests including trunks go
straight to them
this wood is then loaded onto conveyor
belts chipped into sawdust and
compressed into pellets literally tons
of these wood pellets are made every
single day but none of them stay here in
the united states we're following this
truck to see where they go
they're trucked around 90 miles to the
port of chesapeake and shipped to europe
where eu regulators consider pellets a
renewable alternative to coal notably
the us does not there's no real doubt
here that wood pellets and frankly woody
biomass are a far superior climate
change mitigation option than fossil
fuels particularly coal
mit researchers concluded wood burns
dirtier than coal and determined it
takes at least 44 years for replanted
trees to absorb the carbon released from
burning the ones they replaced their dna
is part of this land yeah and it won't
have a change most trees come from
private land owners like hunter darden
iii who credits in viva for creating
thousands of jobs though he tells me
competition
has led to forests being cut younger a
landowner can make more money in a
shorter length of time dealing with
smaller timber than waiting for it to
get to salt timber size a report by the
southern environmental law center found
demand is fueling the additional logging
of tens of thousands of acres a year in
the area impacting wildlife and homes on
the front lines of harvest and those
located near the plants
this is
that's not pollen it's not yellow that
is dust you could see it in the air yeah
and it smells like a lumber yard yeah
laura clark's mother lives next to the
in viva plant in garrysburg north
carolina which is one of the state's
poorest counties it makes you feel like
people don't really care about you and
your health while in viva acknowledges
past issues with dust at other plants
they dispute what we saw near their
garrysburg location it's not coming from
our plants jonathan and listen where is
that coming from then we have tremendous
empathy for anyone who's enduring health
issues uh anywhere but we can
definitively say that we are not the
cause of any respiratory or any other
kind of health issues in the
neighborhood or vicinity of our plants
the ambient air quality around all of
our plants throughout our entire fleet
is tested quite regularly by multiple
sources it's tested by ourselves it's
tested by the epa and viva currently has
11 plans with proposals to build six
more
but critics say in this changing climate
the only growth that needs to happen
is in our forest
the forest that we were in today
those clear-cut degraded forests
could look like this one day
we do have this like enormous
opportunity right now to choose a
different path and to choose a path that
truly is more green
and jonathan vigliotti joins us now
jonathan good morning it's a heck of a
story it definitely gets your attention
when an american woodland area is being
clear-cut not for the benefit of the u.s
but to ship the product overseas and it
raises a big question for me which is
now that we know this is happening
what's the future of this industry
well at this point it is set to expand
and the eu it's important to point out
does recognize this as renewable but
critics say they don't factor in the co2
that is released during the burning
process as a result a lot of subsidies
from the eu are provided to the american
industry leading to that boom another
thing important to point out the white
house at this point has not weighed in
on if they consider wood pellets
renewable though they do provide
subsidies through the infrastructure
bill which critics say stands at odds
with the white house's own climate
agenda we have reached out to the white
house several times over two weeks and
we have not heard back
okay well jonathan vigliadi thank you so
much for that report it's interesting
too i was diving in even the audubon
society has come out and said you don't
just think about the impacts on the
forest itself but please also think
about the impacts on birds and then
insects and how that impacts the entire
ecosystems of these areas and animals
and deforestation and erosion and like
it just trickles all the way down yeah
great peace jonathan wonderful wonderful
job